foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
your money
foreign
[Music]
good evening
welcome to the table
glad that you guys are all here
I can't believe that it is already
November
oh my gosh it's already that time of the
year the change and the time has
happened already oh my goodness woke up
this morning and the Sun is blaring in
my face at 6 30 in the morning
and I'm like this is too much too much
way too crazy
and then it's later on this evening it's
going to be dark at like six o'clock and
my body's gonna be like you need to go
to sleep it's nine o'clock and I'm like
no it's actually six o'clock I have to
stay up for a couple more hours or
something I have to get used to this
it's a weird time change time change
weird strange very strange but anyway
without anyway all that being said just
a couple reminders this is the first uh
Sunday
um of the month yes and we are going to
be doing uh our typical lunch or dinner
uh togetherness uh where it's just focus
on food and fun and fellowship and I
just got my alliteration stuff in there
my Baptist streets coming through but
that is going to be this uh right after
this service so just kind of meet us at
hack Creek that is going to be in uh
Wiley
um or sax excuse me
um then just a couple other little
things excuse me we are doing a baptism
class
that's going to be next Sunday so um
make sure you kind of sign up for that
um that's something you might be
interested in Brent sent out an email
with that how did getting registered and
involved with that so make sure you pay
attention to that but other than that
we're going to get ready for worship
um and everything I know our version of
team is
right behind me just making sure
that was like like are they are they
still still praying okay no they're not
great
so with that being said uh let's uh
start or worship off in the word of
Prayer
Lord thank you so much for just bringing
us all together here this evening
thank you for
um just this opportunity to be together
to just be able to open our hearts and
Minds to be together in the same room to
um share in just joy and laughter and
also just open up our hearts and just
help lift each other a need in prayer I
pray that she just be with us tonight
um and give us the ability just to be
able to
connect with you in Christ I am praying
amen
thanks Tom
um you guys so tonight is a little bit
different than our normal table
situation as I'm sure you've already
noticed like wait a second some people
are missing on the stage
um and largely honestly that is just due
because we have several team members who
ended up sick this weekend and other
people who are traveling and out of town
and so it ended up being just me and
Maggie that were on the schedule that
were left and
so but as we tried to like you know what
I mean scramble and like figure out like
wait a second do we need to reach out
and find a friend or you know I I
thought it was kind of neat in a way
because for those of you who have been
with us for quite a while now I don't
know if you realize we just celebrated
our third anniversary this week was it
Thursday night Thursday
pause for clap yes clapping clapter
um
anyway it was such a special time and a
couple of you were with us this weekend
at the center Beast conference and so we
got to celebrate there together and just
be in an environment of like-minded
people who are trying to figure out how
to follow Christ
um with an inclusive heart and
um as we as we celebrated that like I'm
thinking about what the last three years
have held for us and how many of you are
with us in the kova days where we
weren't even able to meet in person but
we literally had this going in our
review our music room on a screen and
you guys were logging on and we're all
in different places we weren't able to
be together and
um yet somehow we still were um looking
for ways to connect and do worship and
do sermons and do community at a
distance and what a journey this has
been I mean what a crazy three years
this has been and
um you know some of those moments I
gotta be honest were ones I was like are
we ever gonna get out of this this is
this is rough I'm ready to be with my
people I'm ready to be in the same room
I'm ready to hug next I'm ready to sing
and hear other people's voices see other
people's faces
um but now I look back on some of those
moments and I just think about the
goodness of God and his faithfulness in
carrying us through such a crazy
turbulent Unexpected Journey you know
and that's just the kind of God we serve
that's the kind of God who loves us is
come what may highs lows and everything
in between he is faithful to be there
beside us he is faithful to keep leading
us and calling us forward he's faithful
to keep teaching us when we blow it when
we mess up we make mistakes or choose
something that you know really isn't
serving us he's the god that keeps
seeing us and keeps believing in us and
giving us Faith to walk this journey out
and I'm so grateful to walk it out with
all of you I'm so thankful that we're in
person tonight but that even when we're
not when we're in our separate homes
that we have people around us who
believe in Who We Are Who see us as
children of God regardless of
what we've done of where we've been of
how we identify of who we love we have a
community of people who say I see the
good work God is doing in your life and
I love you I love you because you're a
child of God so as we stand together
tonight in worship can we hold that in
our hearts that that gel of Christ's
love that paves the way for us can we
just remember that and and thank God as
we're together alright so you guys stand
with us it's going to be a very
unplugged kind of set with just a
keyboard and two vocals so you guys sing
out with us as you can or if you want to
sit back and just soak it in
um I hope it's just a gift for us
tonight as a community
foreign
[Music]
Eyes Of God
look upon
be my side
[Music]
as I wait
as a way
Heart Of God
[Music]
satisfied
and sustain
as I hear
voice of God
lead me on and be my God
be my
[Music]
above and below me before and behind me
in every Island
[Music]
before and behind me in every eye that
sees me Christ be all around me
[Music]
as I go
hand of God
my defense
by myself
as a rest Breath of God
[Music]
bring me
peace
above and below me before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me above and below me
before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me
all around me
[Music]
above and below me before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me
above and below me
before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me
foreign
[Music]
kiddos you guys are excused to your
classroom go out this front door please
and would you guys join me in Reading
aloud in this prayer of the people and
um if you're online with us can you join
us as well and use the comments uh
section to leave whatever you might feel
Weighing on your heart tonight
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
sickness and disease
please
tool and soon
[Music]
mental health struggles
whoever's birthday it is
[Music]
that was awesome God for the names and
moments that we've spoken aloud and for
those that we have kept in our hearts we
pray to you that they may have life and
Light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
foreign
can you guys sing this I need you more I
need you more
than yesterday
I need you more more than words
say I need you more
[Music]
than ever before
let's sing that one more time I need you
more
more than yesterday I need you more
than words
play I need you more
[Music]
than ever before I need you Lord
more than the air more than the air I
breathe more than the song I see
more than my next
heartbeat
more than anything
and Lord as time goes by
I'll be by your side cause I never want
to go back to my old life I need you
more
than yesterday
I need you more
more than words can say I need you more
than ever before
[Music]
we give you the highest praise we give
you the highest praise we give you the
highest Praise
Jesus sing that again
we give you the highest praise we give
you the highest praise we give you the
highest Praise Jesus we give you
the highest praise we give you the
highest praise we give you the highest
Praise Jesus
[Music]
we give you the highest praise we give
you the highest Praise Jesus
[Music]
more than the air I breathe
more than the song I see
within my next
heartbeat
more than anything and what as time goes
by
I'll be by your side
cause I never wanna go back
my old life I need you more
[Music]
more than yesterday
I need you more
More Than Words
[Music]
please
we live here
Jesus the name above every other name
Jesus the only one who could ever see
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for you
holy for you
holy
holy there is no one like you there is
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
Lead Me In Your Love Lord
worthy of every song
worthy of every song we could ever see
you've all the praise
[Music]
we live for you
Jesus
Jesus the name above every other name
[Music]
seem worthy
there is no one like you there is none
beside you open up my eyes
[Music]
and I will build my life
upon your love
it is a firm foundation
and I will
[Music]
put my trust in you alone
and I will not be Singh holy cause holy
there is no one like you there is none
beside you
open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me
who you are and fill me with your heart
and Lead Me In Your Love to those around
me
is God
I love the words of that chorus
show me who you are and fill me with
your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
God would you fill us with your heart
and would you lead us in that love
with the world around us
be different because we are there
not as a people who are judging but as a
people who are loving
[Music]
not as a people who shy away but as a
people who jump in and support and rally
around
God not as a people who are afraid
but as a people who come boldly before
their God because we know that we are
seen and we are loved
God
with the people that you created us to
be
be the ones that we take into every
space
into every relationship every
conversation would we be a people marked
by you our Creator God
would we be a people transformed because
you have not given up on us you have not
left us behind but you call us by name
you see us and you know us
[Music]
and you're leading a son in your love
you're a good God
full of mercy and compassion
and we want to be marked by that we want
to be your people
giving love and mercy and compassion
everywhere we go
thank you God
for who you are and for who you made us
to be
in Jesus name
amen
thank you guys for being in this space
with us thank you your voices were
Angelic and beautiful it was so nice
being able to hear everyone it's
beautiful would you guys turn to the
people around you welcome them make them
feel at home and Brett is going to get
started on our message
foreign
[Music]
all right well good evening grace and
peace everyone it is uh so so good to be
with you all and for those who don't
know my name is Brett I'm the passenger
here and
um it's just it's a joy just a joy to
worship with you a joy to be together
and
um and a huge thank you to Maggie and
Mindy for leading Us in worship today uh
like Mindy alluded to they um and and
some others Jesse
um Josh Tilford and Gary Miner all LED
worship at centerpiece and initially
they're going to do one set and then I
don't know maybe a month ago or three
weeks ago or something Sally Gary the
leader of centerpiece reached out and
said oh gosh all My Worship bands
canceled can can you lead more like how
much more can you lead every worship set
so of course the whole structure of a
conference is like at least a Christian
Conference you know worship said
it's main session you know then later
maybe a breakout worships that main
session worships that main session
worships that main set worship I mean it
was like literally five or six sets so
they're amazing and uh many of them like
many mentioned needed either we're just
away or just flat out needed a break so
Maggie Mindy pushed through and Lead
another worship said
um so I'm grateful to them uh all right
let's see I want to mention
um if you are new here maybe this your
first second third time you're just
maybe finding your way into the
community thank you thank you thank you
for being with us this is not a church
community that is like closed off to The
Outsiders like hey you're messing up our
Vibe you know like no no no no no
um that's because that's not who Jesus
was
um Christ oh he just extended the
welcome so wide uh in fact that's that's
what eventually got him into a lot of
trouble uh was that that hospitality and
that welcome so we seek to be the that
kind of people
we do it imperfectly but it's what we we
seek to do so um and also they're
showing us online as always love you
love you lots you're not forgotten
um so we are in a series right now
titled stranger things
when the Bible gets weird
and uh we of course totally stole the
title from the Netflix show but uh in
the series as we took kids off we kicked
it off last week so for those of you who
are with us you know we're not like
going to be talking about you know the
upside down or Dungeons and Dragons and
scary creatures
um instead what we're talking about are
basically those weird stories in the
Bible which you know honestly well the
ones that people never preach on or not
never I think one today actually is
touched on
um but you know just those stories that
often leave us sort of um scratching our
head you know when you come across the
story just like I don't know what to
make of that at least that aspect of it
um you know it's the ones that make you
wrinkle the forehead it's sort of you
know it's them
I don't know I don't know what to do
with that uh and so that's that's what
we're doing in this series is touching
on some of those so
um the title of our message tonight is
what's with the whale
and uh this means of course some of you
know the famous story of Jonah the
prophet of God swallowed by what the um
what the scriptures call a great fish
doesn't mean as an awesome fish means
like as tremendously large uh the great
fish and
um you know later Christian tradition
though kind of came to associate it with
a whale I'm guessing maybe it's because
you know when you think of maybe like a
carnivorous fish like a shark you're
thinking it's probably just gonna chop
Jonah you know I mean maybe a whale
feeds with that mouth open he's like
accidentally I don't know
um for various reasons we've come to
kind of associate it with with a whale
and uh
so where I want to kind of um begin here
is just reading a part a key part of the
the story this is Jonah chapter 1 verses
one through five
and it says this the word of the Lord
came to Jonah son of amitai go to the
great city of Nineveh and preach against
it because its wickedness has come up
before me but Jonah ran away from the
Lord and headed for tarshish
he went that was a ancient city he went
down to Joppa where he found a ship
Bound for that Port after paying the
fair he went aboard and sailed for
tarshish to flee from the Lord
and the Lord sent a great wind on this
thief such a violent storm arose the
ship threatened to break up all the
sailors were afraid and each cried out
to his own God and they threw the cargo
into the sea to lighten the ship
now to make a much longer story short
I'll summarized from here uh the sailors
they're absolutely freaking out so they
um do this ancient practice of drawing
Lots this is sort of a way that maybe
the gods could speak or something so you
would draw lots and so they they have
everyone on board draw lots and uh of
course uh sort of like we would draw
straws you know like one of these is the
short one it's based like that and uh
sojona of course he draws the Short
Straw and they're like hey
didn't you say something about running
from God he's like yeah
funny you remember that
um it's true in fact he goes on to
basically convince him he's like you
know what I'm so sorry I've put you all
in Mortal Peril um throw me overboard
and they're like no we couldn't do that
God would judge us and he's like no
seriously um save yourselves I'm guilty
and so he convinces them to literally in
the storm throw him uh overboard
and uh so there he is Jonah now floating
in the water facing almost certain death
we read these words this is verse 17 of
chapter one now the Lord provided a huge
fish to swallow Jonah and Jonah was in
the belly of the fish three days and
three nights
now like our story uh last week we named
that was the the story of the talking
donkey and
um you know recall we named that
um it's often the weird parts of the
story that kind of draw our attention
you know they kind of hook our minds and
then often those weird moments sort of
send us on like a side trail of maybe
questions or debates or arguments from
which
we rarely if ever return
to ask like more important questions
questions like
um what might God be saying to the
church to us to meet you through this
story and of course in the Book of Jonah
or the story of Jonah it's always this
thing about the whale you know and the
great debate was Jonah really swallowed
by a well italicized the word really you
know emphasis really and there's sort of
this hold of it you know like there's
those who are like I don't know it just
strikes me like this is just sort of
mythological and like I don't know about
all this and a guy I mean wouldn't it
like does stomach you know acid
eliminate him quickly you know like
there's all these debates all right and
then there's another side it's like well
you know God can do anything a miracle
is a miracle you know and then back and
forth they go and so you can see how we
just kind of get lost and like well I I
don't think I just don't see that like
being realistic and someone's like wait
at it and you can see where we get so
lost in that conversation
we never come back to ask the question
um what is God speaking to us through
this right so
um that's what I want to do tonight is
is really kind of come back to what
might God be saying not get too lost on
a such such questions
um now so two kind of answer this
question what might God be saying I want
to back up a little bit
um so we noticed the Story begins we'll
read again verse two
it begins with this um command Josh I'm
hearing some feedback I don't know if
you all are hearing it but I'm hearing
it a little bit it might just be me up
here if so I'll be fine but
if y'all hear it
um verse 2 says uh go to the great city
of Nineveh preach against it because its
wickedness has come up before me but
Jonah ran away from the Lord and headed
for Tarsha she went down to Joppa where
he found a shipbound for that Port okay
so as several Scholars have pointed out
basically What's Happening Here is
um Nineveh is
um north and east of where
Jonah currently is he's residing in
Israel and you go north and east that's
Nineveh and so basically what Jonah does
when he receives this word is he heads
where does he go north
he goes south and then does he go east
no he goes west I mean literally it's
kind of like hey Northeast he's like
awesome Southwest it is I mean it's just
the exact opposite like literally just
down and over I mean it's funny if you
look even on a map actually I think we
have uh maybe a picture of this like a
little a little map on a slide and um
there it is you can see where basically
you see where he's sailing
so yeah that's the opposite I mean it's
literally just like straight across it's
like travel it's almost as though God
said like hey uh go to Portland and he's
like Tampa it is you know just the
opposite
um now this begs the question well why
why and you uh astute
local people uh some of you already know
that Nineveh
um was the capital of Assyria
and the ethereans were of course
Israel's dread enemy they were just the
worst and actually if you do some
historical research they really were
kind of the worst like bad bad people
um and the things they would do to their
enemies after like in a war and I mean
impaling that like you're just awful
so you can see why Jonah has this
reaction right he's just like no what
now but what I mean all God told him to
do that was go there and preach right
and even says preach against it which
sounds kind of like hey Jonah you should
be up for this like hey y'all are awful
you know like maybe he should like this
um I think it's that Jonah knew though
that where there's preaching there just
might be repentance you know a change of
heart and where this change of heart
there might be Mercy Mercy instead of
judgment and if you read later in the
book that is of course exactly what
happens
and so he he knows he knows this and so
this is why Jonah gets on that ship and
he goes in the opposite
um Direction now this brings us back to
um the whale and
um you know I think sometimes our
familiarity with you know with a story
it kind of prevents us from experiencing
almost imaginatively entering into the
story as though for the first time you
know once you've read a story it's like
well I already know the ending and it
kind of almost messes up your experience
of reading it or hearing a sermon on it
you know
um and so what I want us to do is kind
of imaginatively like go back into the
story and just imagine that we are Jonah
all right so
okay so there is
had this word from God he God says
Northeast he goes southwest great to the
storm throw him overboard
um and there he is floating in the water
now I'm imagining what Jonah what he
might have been experiencing and I'm
guessing it probably he thought he was
going to die
but I'm just imagining like maybe though
he was holding out hope
you know like maybe who knows maybe a
current could carry me to the shore like
who knows oh God oh God oh God probably
a lot of prayers you know oh God oh God
oh God I'm so sorry
and it's then that he sees 100 yards out
a large mouth
now in that moment
um
what is Jonah like what's going through
his mind
right he's I'm imagining it's sort of
that um that moment where your life
flashes before your eyes you know and
he's thinking like oh my gosh well this
is the end like this is how my story
ends the failed prophet
the failed disobedient child of God
swallowed by a whale
and all of a sudden that thing it comes
and it swallows him up that tongue cat
I'm guessing I'm just going to go with
blue whale I don't even know if they're
in that region that's just always what I
imagine this gigantic you know a
football field of a fish you know just
just that that tongue catapulting him
down the esophagus and there he sits in
the stomach now
there he is now in that moment
see this is where I say because we know
the story we get all messed up we don't
experience it the way the first
listeners might have
so there's Jonah in that great belly
in what's going through his mind is he
thinking
the lord always provides
he makes the way where there seems to be
no way uh no
he's thinking oh my gosh
God is killing me
like this vicious it's it's out to get
me
yeah he's not thinking what a blessing
no
no this is this is the end it's it's
really I imagine that's kind of God's
way he's thinking God's way to bring his
story to a quick end
now um here's what's strange there is a
turning point we know this because
towards the Universe um or chapter one
there's the swallowing and then in
chapter two there's a long prayer and
what's strange about this prayer is that
it is oddly full of Hope
here's chapter 2 verse one I've kind of
we've underlined all the hopeful Parts
in this passage we're about to read from
inside the fish Jonah pray to the Lord
his God he said in my distress I called
to the Lord and he answered me
from deep in the realm of the Dead I
called for help and you listened to my
cry you hurled me into the depth into
the very Heart Of The Seas and the
currents swirled about me all your waves
and Breakers swept over me I said I have
been banished from your sight and yet I
will look again toward your Holy Temple
the engulfing Waters they threatened me
the Deep surrounded me seaweed was
wrapped around my head to the roots of
the mountains I sank down the Earth
beneath barred me in forever but you
Lord my God brought my life up from the
pit when my life was ebbing away I
remembered you Lord and my prayer Rose
to you to your Holy Temple those who
cling now he's preaching those who cling
to worthless Idols turn away from God's
love for them but I with shouts of
grateful praise
grateful praise I will sacrifice to you
and what I have vowed I will make good I
will say salvation comes from the Lord
my question is why why was Jonas why is
this prayer so full of hope I think I
think this is why because at some point
he realized oh my gosh this whale is not
trying to kill me
it is taking me somewhere
which means God is not trying to kill me
God is not trying to judge me
God is taking me somewhere
verse 10 in the Lord commanded the fish
sure enough
and it vomited Jonah on to dry land
there was never a happier person to be
covered in fish vomit
then Jonah
see I think
whales are a Time an event of transition
that we mistake in our own life for an
end
we think whales are an ending God's way
to end our story
when actually they are a beginning
we think whales are God's judgment
judgment in your life
when actually they are God's provision
we think whales are God's harshness
when they just might be his grace
in the year 2011
I've told this story before but
it was pivotal in my life so I'll share
it again it's 2011 and I was laid off
from my my job I worked in the corporate
world then and I was a project manager
and which is a vague maybe the most
vague of all job titles
manage projects which God that's a
mystery
um
but there was I was working this
marketing company and um
and I was I was laid off and
I remember I mean I remember when it
happened I was so shocked
be I mean a because I'd worked so hard
and B I had so many important projects
going like if any of you have jobs you
probably feel like I have important
things going on there's things like if I
weren't here things would drop and it
just feels like I'm essential you know
and maybe even go in like stressed out
like that was me I was like stressed out
every day just like trying I'm trying my
best I'm trying oh my gosh this is so
important it was amazing how a company
could just be like nah
we're good
you know like all these things I thought
oh they can't do without it you know
like apparently they could it was sort
of like um it was like being back in
elementary school and they're picking
teams the kids you know like I choose
Billy
if I choose Susan
I choose David
you know they're just going down the
line and that was sort of it was like
adult
picking teams you know there was they
had to lay off 25 of the people and
um boy you'd think with all my effort
but uh
nope didn't make the cut and I remember
in that like Moment Like honestly it
kind of Hit me hard you know I mean I
was yeah I was in my mid-20s then
and uh
it hit me hard I I was
discouraged I was
I just I think I had a sense of uh
of kind of identity issues value issues
and I think lingering in the back of my
head was some theology God issues too
like aren't you taking care of me like
I'm a Christian I'm like trying to live
Faithfully I don't know it just feels
like you're letting me down you know and
um
here's the thing
a little while later I got hired new new
job new company
and it was closer to Dallas
because of that I ended up going back to
school finished my biblical studies
degree it took me a total of 10 years
but
finished
I tell people I crammed uh crammed four
years of college into ten
not everyone can do that
um
Finnish biblical studies degree to uh
one year after that
started Seminary one year after that I
was pastoring again
and I will tell you 2011 Brett had no
intentions to ever Pastor again
not the plan
not on my radar
what was that layoff
it was the fish it was a whale
God was taking me somewhere
see friends
like Jonah sometimes God in his grace
sends us a whale some situation that we
think is pick your word in ending
judgment harshness suffering
but actually
um it's a beginning
it's a beginning that whale is taking
you somewhere
now perhaps where my analogy breaks down
a little bit
is that in this story
the whale is very clearly a
um
it is a direct thing of God right like
it even it's we've even read a verse
where it's like God sent a whale you
know and where maybe I get a little
messed up is
um I'm what I'm not saying is that God
brings these terrible things into your
life to secretly bless you you know like
or you'll thank him later in 20 years
you know
um that no this is I'm thinking a little
bit more um and this is more of a new
testament view that this
shifts the Bible shifts a little bit
here by the time you come to Christ in
the New Testament who he reveals God to
be you really get the idea that God is
light and love in him there is no
Darkness at all in him there is no
reason to fear at all because God is who
Jesus has revealed the father to be
and and so what that kind of starts to
shift for me is that God doesn't like
bring the terrible circumstances it's
more like this is a fallen world
and crap happens
just how it's just it's bad like
sometimes it's it's our own stupidity
sometimes it's though just others utter
stupidity and or sometimes malevolence
and evil and terribleness
um sometimes just crazy nature and or
maybe even some sort of Darker evil
forces or something I mean there's I
just think there's all sorts of
craziness bad things happen so it's not
what I'm saying to you God um has this
whale it's not that it's the situation
itself what I'm saying is um it's sort
of like the Book of Genesis the story of
Joseph right where all these terrible
things happen to Joseph and I'm not
saying and God caused it all you know
he's like the chess player moving all
the pieces um because what does Joseph
say looks at his um brothers who treated
him so poorly and he says what you
intended for evil God intended for good
in other words God turns it for the good
I that's what I'm naming the whale is
taking this crappy situation just the
worst
and God finds a way
to twist and use it for the good in your
life I'm thinking about like for example
that bankruptcy or soul-crushing debt
and maybe that one well maybe look back
on the spending habits and it's like
yeah
yeah you know but still like in that
moment you were despairing and you're
like this is the end the end of my
financial life which in America means
the end of my life
and in that moment you're so discouraged
but what if it's a whale
launching you into the next season of
your life redirecting you where God
wants you to go or maybe it's about that
church or Community or group of people
that rejected you
you know said you're not welcome here
God can't bless you or you know whatever
language they used
and in that moment you're like see is
this not what always happens to me
projected again
but it's a whale
it's a whale God is
setting You On A New Path placing you in
New communities where you can flourish
or maybe it's that illness that brought
you low I think of Jonah's prayer
brought you down like Jonah into the
depths of sheol the place of the dead
and you thought it was the end of your
story
but what if it's not
what if it's a whale
the beginning of a new you a new chapter
launching you
into new levels of maturity instead
fastness in Christ's likeness or maybe
it was the end of that relationship a
friendship romantic relationship maybe a
divorce
and it humiliated
oriented you and broke your heart
and you feel as though God has thrown
you into the very depths of the sea
Seas of self-judgment and condemnation
and despair
but it's a whale
God is on the Move in your life
you see um we might in closing we might
say that whales aren't cute
at least not when you're inside of one
whales are freaking hell
oh but they're taking you somewhere
they're taking you somewhere
and perhaps even more than um taking you
somewhere which is a very like spatial
metaphor you know like I'm here but I
need to get somewhere else you know and
that's where God can really move in my
life some other place maybe even more
than that it's like God is using that to
shape you into a certain kind of person
less selfish
less judgmental
but more
of a lot of things more kind more
patient more humble more good
just like the Jesus that you love and
follow
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread and the blood of Christ in
the wine we approach the one who himself
went down into the depths of sheol the
place of the Dead who knows what it is
to suffer who knows what it is to
despair but who through Resurrection is
raised to New Life and now offers us
hope
every time you feel like oh my gosh I'm
in a whale and maybe some of you tonight
maybe you've like as I was talking about
all these things you're like yep that's
me right now
um
if so then this table
this table is for you it's for you so
um we practice what's called an open
table
meaning if you were here tonight and you
want to connect with the Risen Jesus
um in this beautiful mystery that
happens in the bread in the cup and you
want to connect maybe you don't have
like all your theology worked out or
something you know but there's something
in you that says yes I need that life I
need that connection to Christ
um then just feel free to come forward
no theological police checking your
credentials
um you just feel free to to come forward
also now that more people are attending
the table we've had a few challenges
with um long lines that then block
people from getting back to this side
since we all filter over here if you
could try to keep it to like maybe I
don't know like maybe eight or nine or
ten people Max basically leave that back
row open so don't all come forward at
once basically
um all right I think that's everything
so let me invite you this is a Celtic
Christian invitation to the table
it says this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
words just are so potent and Powerful
that we had to bring it back it was just
one that all of us were like oh my gosh
these words they just they will haunt
you it's just beautiful it's the gospel
um so if you guys would like to sit back
as you learn it that's great if you know
it or you want to join in please do
but yeah I hope it's one that will
become kind of
um
[Music]
song of sorts for us as a community
a place at the table
for everyone born
a shelter a space a safe place for
growing
for everyone born
a star overhead
[Music]
for woman and man
for a woman and man
a place at the table
[Music]
revising the wrong
deciding the sheds
with wisdom and Grace
[Music]
dividing the power
for woman is man the system that's fair
[Music]
in God
we are creators of Justice
[Music]
compassion and peace
of
justice
justice endures
Justice in joy
[Music]
for gay and for straight
a place at the table
a covenant chair a welcome space
a rainbow of race and gender and colors
foreign
[Music]
when we are creators of Justice
Justice enjoy
[Music]
Justice and joy
uh thank you Mindy Maggie
um that's great you guys are amazing to
do something
you guys are great
oh goodness
it's kind of interesting I did mention
earlier how the seasons change time has
changed it's already dark outside it's
amazing it's six o'clock already
um but one of the things I did think of
during this entire thing especially that
song that was beautiful by the way
um you know those holidays are right
around the corner and that can bring
some very interesting
Dynamics into people's lives some
amazing Beautiful Moments and can also
bring some
challenging things too
um
I say that mainly because we are a
community that
we love each other we're here for each
other
we might be walking into a situation
where there is a whale that we're
currently living in right now
and if that's that's your situation
we are here for you guys I know at the
end of this we always say and I know I
say that I'll be in the back if you need
a high five a hug a prayer or something
like that and if I'm not the right
person for you to do that with and
that's solely fine I don't take it
personally
um find somebody here that will do that
with you
um connect with somebody here we're
about to go off and doing something on
hat Creek that's a great place to
connect
outside of these walls outside of this
structure that we have in the system
that we have going on right now so so
plea please please reach out and let us
let us be able to do that for you guys
if you are a visitor and for the first
time we do have some welcome cards at
the very back there's a small table as
you walk out those doors we would love
for you just to kind of fill that out so
we just have just a little bit of a
record that you're here
and um we'll just kind of see another
things for being here as I mentioned
before if you need prayer or a high five
a hug I will also be standing in the
back if that's something you need
tonight
and then also we do kind of mention that
if you these consider the table your
home you can support this financially
you can do that online you can go to the
website and do that there also because
the holidays is also around the corner
you can go to Amazon I don't know if you
many of you guys know this but you can't
name the table as part of Amazon smile
that's another way of just kind of
giving a little bit back and supporting
this ministry especially since again the
holidays are right around the corner
we're probably doing a lot of online
shopping that's a good way of doing that
but with that being said if you wouldn't
mind you can stand you can sit or
whatever but I want to send you out with
this blessing
[Music]
you are a child of God
you are a child of God and this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
as yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between go filled with
the assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you were accepted Just As You
Are
[Music]
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
have a good rest of the week
[Music]